[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the brand new Last of Us
trailer with just two episodes left we
have two major things that still need to
happen and the first of those is winning
David the new teaser has him and his
people trying to get Ellie whilst Jill
is sitting back kicking his feet up and
just chilling like a villain now there's
lots to unpack this upcoming entry and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down what about there
will be heavy spoilers for what happens
in the game so if you don't want things
ruined then I recommend that you turn
off now if you enjoy the video please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day but out of the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
The Last of Us trailer
he won't survive for long out there
there's room for you in our group if you
want
I mean to question your sense of Mercy
David
she's just another mouth to feed if we
leave her out here she'll die
maybe that's God's will
[Music]
the others want to kill you let me
protect you
now in the trailer David says two major
things he won't survive for long out
there let me let me protect you these
are pulled directly from the game
without very much being a warning and it
also making it seem like he has good
intentions won't survive long out there
I can't protect you
this isn't the case though and Ellie's
arguably in the most danger that she's
ever been in as we see with Joel he's
still out of it and this is a similar
position to how he's in the game during
the winter section Ellie went out
looking for food and she ended up
killing a rabbit before she came across
the deer you see this later on in the
trailer with her aiming down her scope
at it and in the game you were hunting
at using a bow and arrow but after the
whole sniper section in episode 6 I'm
guessing that's why they brought this
across either way I'm thinking things
are gonna play out similar and after
injuring it you tracked it through the
woodlands this point you came across
David and James which is when Ellie said
that she'd let the pair take it in
exchange for medicine an alien David
bunkered down in the cabin connected to
a disused factory this is like what we
see here and at this point infected
swarm them and the pair had to fight it
out whilst working together this really
made you start to trust David as up
until this point all of the characters
that you'd work alongside like this had
ended up being friendlies however David
revealed that the the winter had been
especially cruel and that he'd send some
people out looking for food they'd gone
to a university and all been murdered
which is basically what happened at the
end of episode 6 in the show so all the
people at the University those were
David's men and those that had survived
had come back and said there was a crazy
man and a little girl with him he offers
to take her in even though he's well
aware people will want to kill her at
his camp but because he's the leader he
promises protection from them why is
this though Well turns out I'm getting
the word
yeah that's right creepy David is
actually trying to groom Ellie to make
things worse he and his people are also
cannibals too and they've survived this
long by eating other people on the
trailer we see some of them praying and
it should have David reading from a book
this looks like a Bible and I'm guessing
that he's either a priest or a vicar
who's unite these people through using
faith in the game we don't really learn
anything about him but it seems like
they're going to be fleshing out some of
his backstory and basically telling us
about his past now at one point we see a
woman praying and it looks like he's
thrown together a makeshift Church in
this restaurant we get three shots of it
throughout the trailer and we have him
reading from the book then cut to a shot
at night which is where we can see a big
sign it says when we are in need he
shall provide and this is ripped right
out of the game the chapter with David
culminates with Ellie fighting him in a
restaurant and at the back of it you can
catch us hanging up there's some
guessing it's one and the same and the
final shot the location comes when we
see it on fire David stands there
menacingly whilst the place burns down
around him and we get another shot of
Ellie tucking down in what appears to be
a kitchen this entire segment is ripped
right out of the game and when escaping
David's capture Ali fled through the
town and ended up here as she went to
leave David burst in and when a lamp was
knocked over the entire Place started to
burn down it was like a good Fellas
insurance scam and here Ellie made her
stand which it looks like they're
bringing across to the show it seems
like we're going to be revisiting this
location at numerous points and we'll
probably learn a lot of things that we
weren't privy to in the original game we
never got any of these scenes and due
the fact that we get a wide shot of
David's Home Salt Lake I'm guessing that
we're going to be jumping back and forth
between his and Ellie's perspective he's
very much the Auntie Joel in that he
wants to become a father figure to Ellie
but he has this sick and Sinister side
to him now amongst David's people we
also meet his right hand man James if
you're a fan of the games you'll
probably instantly recognize the person
playing him and this is is none other
than Troy Baker Troy played Joel in the
games and it's so cool seeing him here
so far we've had Marlene's voice actor
playing Marlene Tommy's has played Perry
and now we have Troy making an
appearance as James I think the guy's
amazing he's done so much seminal work
in video games and I see him actually
appearing in the show it's gonna be a
big win now he very much questions
David's motives for saving Ellie and it
seems like he's kind of the voice of
reason amongst all the madness in the
context of the series I see David as
being a sort of play on Kathleen as both
end up causing their own downfall due to
their wants and desires Kathleen was
desperate for revenge and it ended up
costing her everything and David's
desperate for Ellie which too brings
everything down around him now looks
like James is saying this to David or
when his group girl looking for Ellie
originally David wasn't part of this
team in the game but they're probably
bringing him in to make things have this
back and forth with them now in the game
Ellie left David after the cabin scene
and she returned and Hampton as Joel in
the morning she woke up to see that
David's men had arrived looking for her
and she darted out when horseback to
draw them away we see something similar
in the trailer and it looks like Ellie's
racing through the streets on her horse
whilst the men try and shoot at her in
the game the horse ended up being shot
and she then plummeted over the edge of
a cliff which is when you made your way
to a hotel upon escaping this you were
grabbed by David and then he woke up in
a cage his two pops up in the teaser
with David speaking to Ellie through the
mashed bars of it now David at this
point once more offensive protection and
in the game the creepiest side starts to
come out Ellie also discovers that he's
a cannibal during this and the tension
really starts to ramp up on the other
side of this Jill pulls himself together
and he goes looking for her fighting his
way through Salt Lake he arrives at the
restaurant just as Ellie's playing
whack-a-mole on David's head and this is
when the pair is reunited now that
closes out the chapter with Jill
becoming even more of a father to her as
he Comforts her because of what she's
just been through Ellie was really
pushed Over the Edge by David and it's
one of the darkest parts of the game due
to all the horrific subtech sets within
it if David is a holy man you also have
the connotations that come with that too
and this might end up being one of the
strongest episodes in the series it's
great scene try Baker as well and I can
imagine this is going to be a big one
before we head into the finale the week
after success just two episodes left I
don't know what I'm gonna do with my
life after but we still have a lot to
talk about so hopefully I'll see you on
Sunday for a big breakdown on this entry
now in the meantime I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it so make sure you
comment below and let me know if you are
any competition right now giving the
rocky 4K box set to three subscribers on
the 15th of March and all you have to do
to be when the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
lost my voice a bit there uh but yeah
thanks for sticking with me if you want
to be honest to watch then make sure you
check out our operating of the latest
Last of Us episode which will be linked
on screen right now that will really
Riley you up when you see what we've
managed to uncover and definitely go
ahead over there right after this
without the way thanks for sticking
through the video I'll be poor I'll see
you next time yeah you you better come
back mate or it's trouble it's bloody
trouble I tell you see you next week
take care peace